Hoy os presentamos
los candidatos de las distintas formaciones
políticas que concurrirán a las elecciones
catalanas del 12 de Mayo.
El partido socialista de Cataluña
está entregado al liderazgo de Salvador illa,
el que fue ministro de sanidad durante la pandemia.
Asumió el rol de candidato en 2 021
y ahora lidera a la oposición.
Alicia Romero,
portavoz del grupo en el Parlamento,
será la número 2 de los socialistas.
El actual Presidente de la generalidad
y quien decidió el adelanto electoral,
Pedro agonés, repite
como candidato de Esquerra republicana de Cataluña.
Para mantener el gobierno catalán,
vuelve a depositar su confianza
en la que hasta ahora ha sido su vicepresidenta,
Laura vilagra yuns.
Más putemón por Cataluña,
como el propio nombre de la formación lo indica,
el partido independentista deposita toda su confianza
en Carlos putemón,
quien hace unas semanas
anunció que no se presentaría a las elecciones
europeas para centrarse en las catalanas
1 declaración de intenciones
a la que hace unos días
añadió su voluntad de retirarse de la política
si no sale elegido como Presidente.
Ana Navarro, 1, reconocida ejecutiva de Silicon Valley,
debutará en política como número 2 del partido
después de obtener 11 diputados
en las últimas elecciones.
Ignacio Garriga
repite como candidato de Vox
junto a María García Fuster.
Tras 1 período de reconfiguración interna.
Laia Estrada ha sido escogida finalmente
como candidata de la Cup a las próximas
elecciones del 12 de Mayo.
Curiosamente,
es la única formación que presenta 1 dupla femenina
Con Laure Vega como segunda candidata,
los comunes también repiten para estas elecciones.
Candidata será Jessica Albiac,
portavoz del grupo en el Parlament
y que lideró el debate sobre el jarro,
germen del adelanto electoral.
Su número 2 será yusmi yolé,
actual alcalde del Prat de Llobregat,
tras descartar 1 candidatura conjunta.
Carlos Carrizo se Marina bravo,
se presentarán por la formación naranja,
y Alejandro Fernández y Manuel Reyes,
actual alcalde de Casteldefels,
se presentarán por el partido popular. Al hora,
el Nuevo espacio
independentista estará liderado
por la exconsellera y eurodiputada
Clara ponsatí,
y por Jordi graupera.
Silvia orreol
cierra la lista como candidata de Alianza catalana,
el partido de extrema derecha nacido en Ripoll,
municipio que ahora gobierna en solitario.